jetzt beginnt frauke petry die
bundesposition liebe dirigiert wie die
noch nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
m
[Applaus]
ja das bin ich mal einen überraschenden
auftakt des parteitages brauchen dazu
querelen im hintergrund ideal mit
gefährliche liebe delegiert werden
liebe delegierte der ard liebe gäste des
verteidigers die aufgrund der
begrenztheit des raumes diesmal nicht so
viel und fahrig ausfallen konnten wie
vielleicht gewünscht und uns trotzdem
willkommen sind
sehr geehrte vertreter der presse aus
dem innen und aus dem ausland
im namen des gesamten bundesvorstandes
der besorgte brisant der heute noch in
der oper singen muss bereits vollständig
vertreten ist begrüße ich sie alle von
ganzem herzen zu diesem wenn ich richtig
gezählt habe siebten bundesparteitag in
köln ihr auf morgen ja die haben doch
nur gelegenheit jörg wollten und ich
haben uns im vorfeld darauf geeinigt
dass unsere grundsatz leben die auf
solchen parteitagen üblicherweise von
den vorsitzenden gehalten werden sich
dem arbeitsprogramm unterordnen und ich
hoffe dass herr glaser als unseren chef
der programmkommission davon höchst
begeistert ist und wir haben in der tat
hier zu arbeiten auf diesem parteitag
[Applaus]
aus diesem grund der arbeitsteilung sich
daher meine begrüßungsworte nun im
rahmen dieses ersten programmpunkte
sunny und jörg wird seine rede
nachher unter den top sieben halten und
gehen davon aus dass sie als parteitag
mit dieser vorgehensweise einverstanden
sind
meine damen und herren dieser parteitag
stellt in vielerlei hinsicht schon vor
dem eigentlichen beginn eine sehr
besondere veranstaltung dar
im wahljahr 2017 ist es notwendig eine
art der parteitag von sage und schreibe
4000 polizisten und geschätzten kosten
von circa 11 millionen euro bewachen zu
lassen
für diesen schutz ich denke da sind wir
uns ganz einig bedanken wir uns
ausdrücklich
besonders bei den polizisten
wir bedanken uns besonders bei den
polizisten die für uns ihre persönliche
haut draußen auf der straße hin halten
das aber meine damen und herren gerade
die cdu hier in nordrhein westfalen vor
den landtagswahlen versucht die innere
sicherheit für ihre alten und neuen
kernkompetenz zu erklären nachdem sie
jahrelang die pflege der letzten
linksextremistischen szene selbst mit
befördert hat ist einer von vielen
hinweisen darauf dass diese cdu ist
nicht verdient dauerhaft in diesem land
eine führende rolle zu spielen
[Applaus]
angeblich müssen heute in köln unsere
wegen die geschäfte und restaurants
geschlossen bleiben
nach dem motto die asg legt das normale
leben in der domstadt am rhein namen so
oder so ähnlich können sie in vielen
zeitungen lesen liebe journalisten und
sie wissen sie bekommen immer eine
besondere ansprache von uns in der
überschrift eines artikels braucht das
wort antifa nur drei buchstaben mehr als
afd
und ich bin sicher dass sie anstatt
ursache und wirkung zu verwechseln
auch hätten schreiben können es ist bis
zu 50 angekündigte gegendemonstranten
mit dem bekannten hang zur
sachbeschädigung von fensterscheiben
autos und sonstigem eigentum sind wie
die kölner innenstadt rund um den
heimatfest zugaben werden lassen und
gasvorräte angriff verwaltungen dieses
mal offenbar eine armlänge abstand der
linken szene zu den schaufenster nicht
genug war
klick
aber auch die arbeitsgemeinschaft
christlicher kirchen ruft an diesem
wochenende zu nachgegeben und reden
gegen die afd auf weil sie offenbar
zitat hat polarisierung und gegenseitige
abwertung als mittel von politik
vermuten
während die kirchen wirklich moralisch
und ehrlich hätte man vor solchen
hässlichen abwertenden und
polarisierenden bemerkungen einfach mal
unser parteiprogramm gelesen aber das
war offenbar zu aufwendig überraschen
kann uns das leider nicht mehr
denn hier gilt für kirchliche amtsträger
offenbar was für ideologen jeder couleur
richtig ist fakten stören die ideologie
und müssen daher beharrlich ausgeblendet
werden was für ein armutszeugnis 1 500
regierungsjahr der reformation
[Musik]
meine damen und herren nun zu uns
ziemlich genau vier jahre nach unserem
gründungsparteitag in berlin am 13 und
14 april 2013 nimmt die alternative für
deutschland zum zweiten mal anlauf auf
dem deutschen bundestag
im vergleich zu damals sind wir dieses
mal mit vertretern in hunderten
kommunalparlamenten in 11
landesparlamenten und im eu parlament
bereits jetzt eine ernstzunehmende
politische kraft in deutschland geworden
von der viele bürger nicht nur an diesem
wochenende sondern in den nächsten
monaten und jahren erwarten dass wir
unsere stimme für sie die bürger die
wähler und für die bewahrung der
demokratie in unserem land erheben
[Applaus]
die erwarten von uns und das sind große
fußstapfen die wir hinterlassen müssen
dass wir uns mit aller zur verfügung
stehenden politischen macht für die
möglichst rasche korrektur der staat und
identität zerstörenden politik dieser
regierung und vergangener
bundesregierung erheben
und dies gilt meine damen und herren für
die beendigung des ideologischen
projektes euro genauso wie für einen
überfälligen kurswechsel in europa
zurück zu einem europa der souveränen
nationalstaaten die einen wirtschafts
sozial und bevölkerungspolitik nicht in
brüssel und straßburg oder gar in ankara
sondern in berlin paris london und in
den anderen europäischen parlamenten
entschieden wird
als alternative für deutschland sind wir
zugegebenermaßen rein auf der
zeitschiene ein bisschen so etwas wie
ein politischer nachzügler unter den
zahlreichen europäischen parteien die
zum teil seit jahrzehnten das dringend
nötige demokratische korrektiv zur
grenzenlosen multikulturellen und
gesellschaftlich destruktive ideologie
der linken und grünen und auch dazu
nimmt der sogenannten volksparteien dass
wir haben auch wenn es heute noch keine
mehrheiten an wahl ohne in deutschland
sind denn noch millionen deutscher
wähler die hoffnung darauf zurück
gegeben das ist eine demokratische und
vor allen dingen diesmal eine
tatsächlich geistig moralische wende
unserer heimat gibt und wir tragen meine
damen und herren bereits jetzt dafür
einige wichtige verantwortung
[Applaus]
im normalerweise tauchen alter von vier
jahren müssen wir also angesichts der
probleme in deutschland europa und der
welt
die politische reife an den tag legen um
innerhalb der nächsten fünf bis zehn
jahren politische hebel und weichen so
umzulegen dass die vorhersehbaren folgen
einer vermögens vernichtenden
währungspolitik einer illegalen
migrationspolitik gegen das eigene volk
einer mittelstandsfeindlich energie und
arbeitsmarktpolitik und auch einer
zunehmend demokratiefeindlichen
bildungspolitik gemildert und im besten
fall verhindert und endlich
durchsuchungs weisen alternativen
ersetzt werden
meine damen und herren nicht weniger als
das was ich gerade gesagt habe war auch
schon 2013 im wesentlichen der gründungs
anspruch der alternative für deutschland
nicht mehr ist es heute im jahr 2017
aber sie wissen um die gigantische
gesellschaftliche aufgabe dieser partei
wir kommen an diesem wochenende hier
zusammen und mit dem wahlprogramm eine
inhaltliche festlegung für diesen
wahlkampf und die kommende legislatur im
bundestag zu beschließen und ich bin der
festen überzeugung dafür zusätzlich den
wähler eine ehrliche ansage darüber
schuldig sind auf welche weise wir im
gleichen zeitraum politik machen wollen
sowie über den abstimmungen über das
wahlprogramm davon ausgehen dass auch
bei knappen entscheidungen zum beispiel
55 zu 45 prozent
die unterlegene minderheit das
mehrheitsvotum nicht nur grummeln sie
erträgt sondern öffentlich mitträgt und
offensiv verteidigt so ist diese
akzeptanz demokratische entscheidung bei
anderen also auch bei strategischen
fragen ebenso wichtig
warum weil wir in der partei gerade in
den letzten zwei jahren auch schmerzvoll
gelernt haben
das außenbild unserer partei immer auch
auf durch das agieren 10 und nicht auf
bundesebene dafür gewählter
protagonisten auf allen ebenen so
nachhaltig geprägt wurde das die
mehrheitsmeinung der mitglieder in der
öffentlichkeit daher als zu oft
verschwindet gerade wenn wir in der
alternative für deutschland darauf sind
zu recht stolz eine lebendige
diskussionskultur und ein breites
meinungsspektrum haben und
selbstverständlich erhalten wollen muss
uns daher die entscheidung darüber wie
wir diese politische kultur nach innen
leben und gleichzeitig nach außen ein
einiges bild abgeben wichtig sein und
bedürfen sie nicht dem zufall und der
politischen geschlossenheit einzelner
akteure überlassen
[Applaus]
in der diskussion rund um den von mir
und anderen eingebrachten zukunfts
antrag habe ich die abneigung vieler
mitglieder vor einem erneuten
innerparteilichen konflikt oder vor
spaltungstendenzen als starke motivation
wahrgenommen einen solchen antrag
möglichst nicht oder schon gar nicht
öffentlich und schon gar nicht jetzt vor
der bundestagswahl diskutieren
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren emotional kann
ich sehr gut verstehen warum sich viele
mitglieder zu fühlen aber politisch
lassen sie uns bitte es bei dem gefühl
nicht belasten sondern ihnen auf den
grund gehen
warum haben viele armeemitglieder davor
solche angst dass sie eine grundsätzlich
als richtig und notwendig empfunden
festlegung wie sie zum beispiel auch die
berliner fraktion mit der entscheidung
wird den berliner kurs passwort gleich
mit dem antrag formuliert hat lieber
nicht treffen wollen
ich möchte darauf eine antwort versuchen
sie ist immer subjektiv aber das steht
jedem natürlich gleich verteilt auf die
männer verteidigen konflikt vor dem
essener parteitag 2015 gelernt dass
öffentlich ausgetragener streit zu recht
vom wähler deutlich abgestraft wird wir
wissen aber auch dass die ursachen
damals andere waren dass es eine
programmatische und satzungs technischer
verengung der art wie geben sollte
die natürlich die mehrheit der parteien
ich wollte aber nichts mehr damen und
herren ist heute nur ansatzweise der
fall so viel gehört zur ehrlichkeit dazu
[Applaus]
die partei hat seit dem sommer 2005
finden aber auch in zunehmendem maß
erfahren dass es minderheiten auf allen
ebenen gibt die insbesondere
demokratische beschlüsse von vorständen
und linien gemeinsame erklärungen
zusatzfragen oder auch über einen
verhaltenskodex immer wieder auch
öffentlich torpedieren und zwar ohne
dass sanktionen der partei folgen die
alle kennen solche beispiele aus ihren
kreisverbänden und sie wissen dass es
selten ein innerparteiliches privileg
ist sie für die ard in parteiämter
wählen zu lassen
dabei werden demokratische beschlüsse
vor schnell und ohne umfassende kenntnis
der faktenlage als missachtung der basis
und spaltung versuch verurteilt
ich könnte auch ein bisschen provokant
formulieren die spontane und auch über
facebook twitter und mail verteiler
verbreitete solidarität mit minderheits
meinungen und auch verfehlungen
einzelner protagonisten ist häufig
größer als die solidarität mit gewählten
vorständen und offiziellen
repräsentanten
und selbst im damen und herren wenn man
solche skepsis grundsätzlich angesichts
anderer parteien verstehen kann dann ist
es doch schon die frage warum es immer
schon gleich als anbiederung gilt sie
auch öffentlich und deutlich vor die von
einem selbst demokratisch gewählten
repräsentanten zu stellen
denn es wird dabei leider übersehen dass
der gesamtschaden für die ard aus sicht
der wähler der öffentlichkeit der bürger
eben auch dann entsteht meine damen und
herren wenn es nur einzelne vertreter
sind die aus parteikreisen angegriffen
werden ich glaube das muss nicht sein
vor solchen konflikten also und da bin
ich emotional bei all denjenigen die es
nicht möchten
vor solchen konflikten haben inzwischen
viele mitglieder ganz berechtigt angst
und sorgen und die wollen deswegen aus
einem sehr wohl gemeinten menschlichen
beschützer instinkt heraus jeglichen
konflikt lieber vermeiden
es ist verständlich aber nicht hilfreich
und vor allen dingen meine damen und
herren ist ist nicht gut ich es wird
neben ich dabei nur allzu leicht
übersehen dass durch diese art der
konfliktvermeidung in anspruch der
demokratischen mehrheit über das
schicksal einer partei demokratisch zu
entscheiden
vielleicht aufgegeben haben und dass
dieses schicksal gegebenenfalls eben
auch einer laute minderheit überlassen
wird
meine damen und herren wende es uns
diese mut zur wahrheit also tatsächlich
noch ernst ist dann müssen wir uns diese
frage beantworten müssen sie mit ja
beantworten dass die mehrheit eben
häufig lieber schweigt als entscheidet
dann sind wir dabei den
innerparteilichen mehrheits anspruch den
demokratischen mehrheit an spruch stück
für stück zu beerdigen und wenn nein
meine damen und herren dann bitte ich an
dieser stelle ausdrücklich um den mut
und die entschlossenheit nicht nur gegen
politische fehlentscheidung der merkel
regierung und anderer kraftvoll
aufzubegehren sondern sicher auch
innerhalb unserer eigenen partei dafür
zu sorgen dass demokratische mehrheiten
unter anderem auch um die strategische
ausrichtung dieser partei festgelegt und
anschließend gemeinsam und in einheit
umgesetzt werden
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren niemand ist
fehlerfrei und ich bin mir bewusst dass
die sehr deutliche begründungen des
zukunfts antrags mitglieder erschreckt
hat und dass viele befürworter in der
sache vor allem nicht damit
einverstanden waren und sind dass ich
neben meiner person als antragssteller
auch meinen vorstandskollegen alexander
gauland namentlich benannt habe obwohl
ich lassen sie mich als würde sagen
obwohl ich von ihm persönlich aus vielen
gesprächen weiß dass einen erfahrenen
politiker wie ihn sachlich politischer
streit in der sache nicht erschüttern
kein tut es mir leid und sage ich ihm
auch gesagt dass er sein zitat sowie
zahlreiche mitglieder möglicherweise als
persönlichen angriff verstanden hat zu
verletzen das sage ich hier ganz
ausdrücklich vor dem parteitag lag nicht
in meiner absicht und war in diesem
kontext ein fehler von dem ich aber
hoffe dass wir ihn gemeinsam mit einer
umformulierung des sektes auf der welt
schaffen können
[Applaus]
foul an und ich haben uns im vorfeld
darauf geeinigt und entsteht zusätzlich
schon wenn sie sowohl mögen ein
redaktionsteam bereits den text
anzupassen und vergabe und ich sind
beide bereit in diesem kino unter
anderem mit zu arbeiten wenn sie als
delegierte das so entscheiden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine damen und herren es ist innerhalb
von parteien und ich glaube da lohnt ein
blick nach außen an dieser stelle völlig
normal dass politische strategien immer
auch mit personen mit verschiedenen
personen verknüpft werden sowie
politische inhalte für den wähler immer
auch einen bestimmten gesichtern hängen
insofern kommt es jetzt meiner ansicht
nach darauf an eine demokratische
entscheidung für die gesamte partei
herbeizuführen die für den wähler
klarheit darüber schafft wie wir und das
ist die entscheidende aufgabe die
politischen geschicke dieses landes
möglichst schnell entscheidend
mitbestimmen können
lassen sie mich deshalb und auch hier
hänge ich mitnichten an wörtlichen
definitionen zum beispiel von real oder
fundamental politik folgendes fragen
erheben wir als es dem 2010 und in den
darauf folgenden jahren den anspruch die
breite schichten der bevölkerung zu
erobern
auch die bürgerlichen schichten berlins
bekanntermaßen am schwersten fällt die
für grundsätzlich unsere inhaltlichen
positionen einnehmen könnten es aber
aufgrund des negativen außenbild unserer
partei egal ob berechtigt oder
unberechtigt und wir sind uns einig dass
es in den allermeisten fällen wer
unberechtigt ist und wir immer noch
damit verbundenen ächtung nicht tun
ein zur wahrheit gehört in der tat eine
verbindung der fdj mitglied oder
repräsentanz mit einem massiven verlust
der sozialen gesellschaftlichen und
häufig auch arbeitsumfeldes einhergeht
oder meine damen und herren und das wäre
eine demokratisch und völlig legitime
entscheidung halten wir unser image in
der öffentlichkeit letztlich für
zweitrangig akzeptieren dass in einer
jungen partei die so genannten roten
linien de facto kaum durchzusetzen sind
und halten nur den bedingungslosen
zusammenhalt für das erfolgsrezept der
nächsten jahre bei dem die anderen
parteien die den schieren druck der
öffentlichkeit und der sich
wahrscheinlich weiter zuspitzenden
folgen der illegalen migration der
terrorismusgefahr und weiterer nahender
um rettungspakete genug
gesellschaftlicher sprengstoff vorhanden
ist um sich als politische kraft
dauerhaft zu verankern
liebe delegierte anders als aus
parteikreisen gern behauptet wird geht
es neben diesem antrag nicht vielmehr
darum die mehrheit um jeden preis zu
erwirken
die kontroversen diskussion hat diesen
letzten wochen eindrucksvoll bewiesen
dass die vergrößerung der machtbasis und
das vertreten aigner
aber vielleicht auch strittiger
standpunkte genau dazu nicht geeignet
ist das weiß jeder roten kreis verbinden
wenn ich als vorsitzender von einem
überzeugt bin dann davon dass wir als
ard den wähler vor den landtagswahlen in
schleswig-holstein nordrhein-westfalen
aber vor allem wegen vor den
bundestagswahlen auf zeigen müssen ob
und wie die alternative für deutschland
in jahren bis 2021 als eine realistische
machtoption für die wähler aufbauen
müssen damit wie das spielfeld und auch
die regierungsbank nicht dauerhaft den
etablierten parteien und ihren grünen
unterstützen da draußen überlassen
da bei zweifeln der eigenen erkenntnis
überall auf der welt auch keinen
deutschen wähler zeit braucht müssen wir
damit jetzt beginnen und nicht erst im
jahr 2021
lassen sie uns daher auf diesem
bundesparteitag den bürgern und der
politischen öffentlichkeit in
deutschland und außerhalb zeigen dass
die alternative für deutschland bereits
jetzt den politischen horizont einer
erwachsenen und dennoch demokratisch
kontroversen partei ohne verlust ihrer
gründungs inhalte und gründungs ideale
hat und ich glaube der verteidiger kann
die chance dazu
das zu beweisen
[Applaus]
liebe delegierte lassen sie uns allen
medialen unten rufen zum trotz zeigen
dass die asd aus einem demokratisch
ausgetragenen konflikt gestärkt
hervorgeht und dass wir tatsächlich in
dieses politische deutschland gekommen
sind um zu bleiben und dieses land und
europa zu einer neuen demokratischen
blüte führen werden
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
so und jetzt habe ich die ehrenvolle
aufgabe diejenigen zur wahl anzukündigen
die diese versammlung bis morgen abend
leiten werden
wie sie wissen wählen wir laut satzung
ein versammlungsleiter und der daraufhin
noch zwei stellvertretern
es gibt einige fleißige die sich
daraufhin letzten tagen schon
vorbereitet haben und von philipp roemer
wurde ich gebeten
jochen hock der als zu sammlungsleiter
bundesweit bekannt und berühmt ist dazu
vorzuschlagen wenn er denn bereitsteht
ja meine damen und herren das war also
eröffnungsrede der bundesvorsitzende
frauke petry die mit einem ablauf
stehend angefangen hat und auch mit
einem applaus stehend beendet hat so
dass